[Music]
hello there
by now we all know that fortnite story
is never spoon fed to us
we have to put in effort to understand
everything from map updates to secret
agencies to
understanding why crossover characters
are suddenly on the island
i mean except for making epic bank as
each season arrives new lore is here
if we choose to decipher it so that's
what we're gonna do today
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamarrow in the shop to
support overthinking videos like this
and let's find those clues
[Music]
first up the unexplained ufo during the
opening trailer for season seven
it was possible to spot an alien flying
saucer underneath the ground
it's on screen for less than two seconds
before everything moves on and we forget
about it but there are things to note
here
judging by the suited duo who found the
crash site these are likely io
operatives
as you know in season seven io buildings
outposts and hidden facilities
are pretty much everywhere and inside we
can see the imagined order analyzing
everything about the alien invaders from
the mothership
to their own counter measures and here's
the thing look closely enough and you'll
discover this screen
a ufo much smaller than the mother ship
but much larger than the ones in game
leading me to believe this is a scan of
the buried ship
in the trailer now here's the thing we
can use the basic shape of the island
to find the exact spot of that alien
vessel
recognize it it's steamy stacks
this changes many things firstly this
directly links the alien ships to kevin
the cube
but i reckon we all figured that out
already and this also confirms the vat
of purple juice
is directly above the ufo remains
harnessing its energy from the first day
of chapter two
if we need extra confirmation listen to
the very first line in the season 7
trailer again
then the rest of them showed up
then the rest showed up proving that
alien life was known before the invasion
pretty cool stuff
next the history of dr sloan since her
reveal in the zero crisis event
we've all wondered who sloane is and if
she is jonesy's boss
season seven has come to our aid with a
bunch of info about the woman with the
best hair in video games
deep in the hidden facility we can find
dr sloane's office
everything is how you'd expect clean
lines no dust few pictures on the wall
these pictures are what we're going to
concentrate on the first one which
catches our attention
is the day sloan was recruited into the
io
the dude next to her is the next person
we are all trying to identify
i think we can all agree he must be a
high-ranking io boss
but here's a cool theory that's floating
around some people believe
this dude is geno think back to last
season and the word which stopped the
foundation from beating the crap out of
jonesy
i can get you to geno jenno it works a
little better if we gave him a first
name too
meet dave geno does that work you can
have that for free epic games
dave geno io commanding officer sounds
damn cool to me
i personally still think geno is a place
rather than a person
but this theory keeps everything in a
nice tight little bow of convenience
is this geno
[Music]
[Applause]
now to the image next to it in this one
it's pretty clear to see that sloan is a
child prodigy
her mathematical and scientific
knowledge was off the charts
even before she became an adult law wise
we know she's damn intelligent but
here's another thing
those exact equations are still being
used to this day
look around the office further and
you'll spot them so either she became an
adult overnight
or those equations from that classroom
are key to how io run the loop and
interact with us
and if that's right that explains why
she's here firsthand
to try and save her life's work but wait
there's more
back to the chalkboard image it has been
noticed that the characters in the
foreground with their backstores can be
identified
the theory goes that this is midas and
this one down here
is marigold this theory goes deep let's
go as we all know midas is the
mastermind of season two who attempted
to stop the storm
and escape the loop after that point we
saw midas eaten by a shark
but a season later bunker jonesy told us
that was not the same midas
it was simply a snapshot the og midas
vanished on the day of the device
this season that is backed up by another
incoming quest
in which marigold says i don't
understand how midas could have just
vanished in game we can jump further
into this rabbit hole by talking to
marigold herself she's down at lazy lake
depending on who you choose to visit her
with you will get different responses
like asking us to be a getaway driver
most of the time
marigold will comment one step closer to
the answers
but now return to her as midas and
she'll remark this
it's happening soon just in case you've
been living under a rock
just like the myth of midas the
fortnight midas is pretty much the same
thing it's kind of like the norse
thor and the marvel thor technically
different
but kind of the same too midas's golden
touch in myth
turned his daughter marigold into gold
and in fortnite
it is confirmed that marigold is indeed
midas daughter
but think back a few seasons because he
has another daughter
so midas technically gets around more
than your mum ah sorry i said no my mum
jokes i'm sorry pretend that didn't
happen
my point is though that midas has
another daughter in the loop
jules and by visiting marigold with
jewels
she'll say stick to the plan confirming
that the sisters
are planning something so the real
question now is if sloane
is working with the midas girls or
against them
they've been watching her for a long
time so it seems just going back to the
geno point earlier
what if geno is midas in the real world
and that would make his daughters the
sisters that the foundation wants to
locate
just a side thought i can't back that up
but that does make a lot of sense
[Music]
next the agent jones issue so last
season jon jones broke away from the io
and tag teamed with the seven he then
found himself locked in the loop
destined to slowly lose his memory and
become just another snapshot
the thing is io are now back on the
island and johnsy must be pretty high on
their list to be found
the way they're moving on from this part
of the story is quite impressive
the guernsey skin has jones hiding his
identity by
wearing a cow costume we've all been
there at some point we know that
feelings carry over
so even if jonesy has forgotten why he
needs to hide from the io
at least he still feels the urge to hide
his backbling confirms everything the
disappearance of agent jones with a
missing person ad
hopefully his story will be back soon
but if it's not i thought this was a
clever way to put his story to the side
while we concentrate on other things
gg's epic
[Music]
finally a question that needs to be
addressed did the mothership blow up the
zero point
as we all know the zero point is key to
the storyline of fortnite
it's the source of energy which can
power entire cities
it's the lure that brings beings wanting
to destroy it
and it's how the io get into the loop
safely
in season seven the zero point is no
more or so it looks
but let's go back a season to see what
really happened while agent jones
hatched a plan to join forces with the
seven
dr sloan is heard saying this the zero
point isn't floating
we've lost control save yourself the
zero point is imploding
we've lost control imploding would see
the zero point collapse
upon itself and it's happened before
remember this
yeah we were sucked into a black hole
the opposite of that would be an
explosion which would have wiped us all
out
so we can safely say that didn't happen
because we're all alive and kicking
so the zero point is somewhere here
still what likely happened was the
mother ship blasted off the foundation
spire removing him from the zero point
before extracting that power straight
into the mothership by using its
apertures
or anuses as i prefer sorry sorry
youtube our reality remains intact at
least for now
indicating the zero point is here
this info suddenly makes sloane's call
to action make sense as the zero point
is still there to be fought for
we either need to destroy that mother
ship or get on board
before it leaves what do you think will
happen next
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome i'll see you on wednesday for
the next batman fortnite issue
sorry i don't have any legends names in
this video they'll be back in the next
one and i'll be thanking everyone who
rocked my code to grab the battle pass
thank you so much for supporting me
it's truly appreciated